back with my pack tonight here with talk
TV contributors Esther cracker and Paula
Ryan Asia well welcome to you ladies uh
Stephen A Smith he's a smart guy yeah
really funny interesting funny yeah but
even he who does a book called straight
shooter even he gets basically bullied
into apologizing for basically just
saying even the first Beyonce dies he
didn't apologize and he told you he
didn't apologize
it's a three-minute apology because he
was concerned that she made missing
exactly yeah
and he was right to be concerned who is
better Beyonce or Rihanna
really
I don't think the nation's quite ready
for me twerking on the table I think you
underestimated talking of singing uh Sam
Smith uh he they them she whatever he
currently calls himself that she does
whatever they see I can't call one
person there yeah I have a problem with
that there's only one because you can't
get your head around it
they can't either because they keep
practically incorrect their minds what
they are no it's not their problem it's
your problem they was a gay man came out
as gay then he said actually I'm now
non-binary yes then then something else
and now they have got the goal to come
out and say that the Brit Awards Fiasco
where all the nominees are better of
course are men because they made it
gender neutral so the men dominating so
you're accepting about the sex
discrimination that still exists
I'm classic than a woman because the
five years
because the five well oh so you make it
gender neutral to avoid discrimination
and when the five best artist
nominations actually turn out to be men
that year that's discrimination against
women but no one was surprised what
about going back to having best women
and best men which was what old Sam
Smith they wanted to stop right they
wanted it to stop they wanted non-binary
to get the same part of the pie as men
and women and guess what now he wants
more women to be nominated really Sam
Smith they
how do I even speak to they the reality
is and the reason why you're getting so
tired the reason why you're exhausting
and it's true it's exhausting it's true
because somebody's gay one minute the
non-binary but next they want women
removed from award ceremonies they'll
want gender neutral Awards and then when
it all turns out that no women get
nominated that becomes sexism then he
then they wants to have more women
there is no such thing as awoke War this
is you oh no there is
excited and exhausted there is about a
myth no there is we need to dispel that
no okay this is
about them discovering going on a
journey
it is ridiculous and you need to keep up
with that and you're strong
we don't need to stop I can't actually
keep up with Sam Smith
Their identity so often from he to she
to they to whatever I can't keep up with
it and why did why does that why should
I have to and why does that happen how
many women do you think were asked for
their permission to whether they think
the women's category should be removed
exactly how many women do you think
the whole thing was ridiculous
that decision was made effectively by
people backing this man it is it is
literally the patriarchy yeah the fact
that one confused man which is what Sam
Smith is said oh but we don't want to
identify as male or female and so they
removed the female I'm not sure
he's obviously confused I I I'm not sure
he would agree with you if you find
anything
you just misgendered Sam Smith I did and
I apologize please apologize today I
apologize
today please
I didn't mean to do that you see how
easy it is it is easy but what we need
to do is have this conversation
if I said my pronoun was hottest man
alive because that was my genuine
pronoun would you feel obliged to call
me that every day hey hottest man alive
no you wouldn't no so in other words it
all depends who decides what they want
to be isn't that what we're discussing
the fact that I don't have to do that
why do we have to call Sam Smith because
we're respecting
that's my choice it's my choice
hottest man alive hottest man alive all
the time that is my choice and I demand
you respect it
well I once identified as a two-spirit
penguin because I was told there are a
hundred genders including astragender
which is an affinity with the Stars and
I was told peers stop being ridiculous I
was like if there are 100 genders I can
be a two-spirit penguin I can now demand
you call me is my pronouns hardest man
alive but you don't want to because you
think that's ridiculous theories single
person they and them the serious part of
this conversation is about people who do
not fit into your box and you struggle
with that here's where I struggle
struggle with yeah let me answer here's
my problem with Sam Smith
they said when they weren't actually
they when they were a gay man they said
we need to even up these award
ceremonies by making them all gender
neutral I demand it it's now happened
and they as the former gay man that
wants us to call him now says it's
terribly unfair and we've got to have
more women they are responsible for
where we've got to because changing a
name doesn't change the
districts but you know what the good
thing about the tour is there's always
time tomorrow because there'll be more
of it by tomorrow